c'est pas le bon soir année bonsoir
julie avez vous été surprise à sa
décision vous attendiez à ce bain je
m'attendais à ça c'était la décision à
prendre compte tenu des circonstances et
une élection c'est jamais facile l'avoir
vécu mais aussi en 2010 et en 2010 on
pense pas perdre mais quand ça arrive ça
arrive deux fois pour l'avenir du parti
pour les collègues qui sont le c'était
la décision c'était la bonne décision
parce que la reprise mais quand il dit
je quitte la vie politique pour de bon
les journalistes y ont posé la question
mais monsieur coderre si je vais vous
avez une offre au fédéral et au
provincial
il a dit non non non je ne serai pas
tenté mais c'est quand même un homme que
la politique dans le sang est-ce qu'il
peut se permettre de dire jamais il faut
jamais dire jamais mais le fédéral il
connaît déjà le municipal il le fait
souvent ça dépend son état d'esprit
actuellement c'est sûr que maintenant le
aujourd'hui après une défaite on veut
pas retourner l'on est en deuil à faire
on a assuré être remémorer puis où ça
c'est de trouver sa place quand tu fais
ça toute ta vie la politique tu fais
quoi le lendemain de l'élection il faut
que tu te définis structure découvre ce
que tu veux faire comment tu veux le
faire donc il va au besoin de cette
pause là pour se retrouver se retrouver
lui-même puis essayer de voir où il veut
aller après est-ce qui vous retourne en
poétique peut-être goût aussi goût lui
revient dans quelques années il va
peut-être trouvé pizza et rauque et j'ai
encore le goût il va peut-être faire
autre chose aussi ça va dépendre ça va
dépendre de ce qu'il veut avait beaucoup
d'émotion dans son point de presse on a
vu les yeux le se remplir d'eau il
parlait aussi de l'aide à quel point
c'est dur lui le trouver sur dur la
campagne électorale il parlait de
l'homme réel derrière le client qui a
essaimé coup il s'est parfois j'aurais
je me serais fâché il ya deux sortes et
bakol je me suis retenu on n'a pas idée
nous quand on est de l'autre côté et
qu'on fait simplement commenté puis
observer les policiers repas et d'un
quel point ça peut être difficile c'est
extrêmement moi j'ai fait cette campagne
le à titre d'élu j'en ai fait d'autres
organisations mais c'est du lourd c'est
dur une campagne électorale si on rentre
comme dans une boule avec la neige de
dalles puis on vit tous en accélérer
toutes les émotions et tout ça est ce
comme un sprint puis du jour au
lendemain tout s'arrête plus rien plus
de relations avec les gens l'adrénaline
et pu le donc c'est sûr que même pour
mes collègues actuellement ceux qui sont
élus ceux qui ont perdu leur élection
c'est pas facile non plus et l'occasion
arrive maintenant ou le parti pour se
redéfinir parce qu'un rôle dans
l'opposition c'est un rôle extrêmement
important c'est un décès les chiens de
garde en fait de ce qui va se passer et
pour les nouveaux collègues qui se
joignent à l'équipe c'est extrêmement
intéressant de comprendre et de vivre sa
politique municipale en étant dans
l'opposition moi j'ai fait j'ai eu la
chance de faire le pouvoir l'opposition
et le pouvoir et ça nous permet de voir
les dossiers entre les lignes de mieux
comprendre et quand vous allez retrouver
du pouvoir vous allez encore beaucoup
mieux préparés pour pouvoir développer
une expertise sur les connaissez vos
dossiers annie la rencontre a été très
longue quand même aujourd'hui et puis on
a vu on a vu dans les médias ont entendu
des candidats qui ont perdu qui est en
colère contre monsieur coderre qu'ils
incitent sa folle ce sont ces erreurs
j'étais en cas si finalement tout sûr
j'étais victime un peu tout ça il
fallait ces gens ne se parlent dans le
blanc des yeux aujourd'hui il y en a qui
avait manifestement des comptes à régler
vous vous avez déjà vécu ce genre de
rencontre post mortem comment ça se
passe derrière les portes ou pense que
ça s'est passé comment aujourd'hui ben
c'est ça c'est sûr que là c'était le
moment où tout le monde se retrouver
parce qu'il y avait pas des rencontres
en présentiel à toutes les semaines ce
que je semblé comprendre donc c'était
par zoom c'était vraiment le moment où
la famille se retrouvaient où nous tous
ces gens là ont vécu la même panoplie
d'émotions donc l'adrénaline la joue la
rapidité rencontrer les gens la pression
les émotions assez à leur maximum et
aujourd'hui c'était important pour
rupture rencontrer de se revoir juste le
fait de se revoir puise rebond en total
gagné bravo dois te perdu et c'est
vraiment un moment intense intense
d'émotion où justement il ya des gens
qui vont dire ce qu'il pense ça va leur
faire du bien chacun sait vivre un deuil
et chacun le vit à sa façon de façon
différente probablement mais le fait de
se revoir c'est important déjà ça de
retrouver l'équipe le sens d'une équipe
et c'est parfois un adieu pour certains
parce que des candidats défaits et
parfois belles vont reprendre le cours
de leur vie rendues là mais le ballon du
parti n'y a pas de chef annie monsieur
coderre s'envole lionel perez s'est fait
battre ces collations avait réussi oui
il ya des banlieues des bonnes personnes
qui sont parties des personnes qui
étaient là les plus vieilles dents au
conseil municipal qui maîtrisait
l'ensemble des dossiers il ya des
nouveaux qui arrivent c'est bien c'est
aussi parce que ça fait du renouveau
aussi dans les candidats il n'y a pas de
chef évidemment ce pour aujourd'hui
qu'ils étaient pour le choisir ils vont
prendre un temps de recul durant la
semaine prochaine j'imagine que ça
devrait se faire par la suite donc
erreur il y aura deux trois quatre
personnes peut-être qu'ils vont sentir
qu'ils vont sentir qu'ils ont les
capacités pour pouvoir y aller a pour
ces faux laval aussi des élus qui sont
là pour se choisir la meilleure personne
s'est passé pour cette personne là qui
va probablement se présenter aux
prochaines élections
mais le chef de l'opposition un gros
rôle à jouer donc d'un peu comme le
position dans ce moment et à le faire
dans les quatre dernières années et en
fait quand même un excellent travail
donc c'est demain la même dynamique qui
va y avoir donc une personne qui vote
qui vaut être qu'il va être le chef une
femme ou un homme et les autres vont
pouvoir travailler en équipe aussi pour
défendre les dossiers avec un parti qui
est en santé donc jugé dans quel état il
est parti en ce moment et et j'ai pas vu
les chiffres ce qu'on m'informe ce que
mon petit doigt me dit si financièrement
le parti sera en bois en bonne situation
ce qui permet maintenant aux gens de
pouvoir redéfinir le parti donc laisser
le temps comme à chaque crise eu des
opportunités
et là c'est l'opportunité de se
réinventer de se redéfinir
dirt choisir les priorités de décider
comment on peut être un parti opte
d'être lausanne et 2021 avec les
nouveaux besoins et ils ont une occasion
importante de le faire maintenant et
pour les quatre prochaines années donc
immenses comme un phénix qui vont
rentrer ses cendres donc le parti encore
cette occasion depuis moi j'y crois moi
j'y crois parce qu'ils ont l'occasion de
faire tous ces changements là c'est ça
il faut tourner ses pages vite en
politique il faut regarder en avant puis
découvrir les nouvelles opportunités
c'est un peu ce que je saisis de votre
message à denis samson merci beaucoup
pour l'analyse ce soir merci au revoir